In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for October 1st, on which we commemorate, St. Romano's
the Melodist.
Our Holy Father Romano's was from Emesa, in Syria.
He became Deacon of the Church of Berritos, Beirut, and settled in Constantinople during
the reign of the Emperor Anastasios I, about the year 496.
His virtuous life was a shining example to the faithful, and he fulfilled his duties conscientiously
at the Church of the Mother of God of Cyrus, to which he was appointed.
But Romano's had not been blessed with a well-modulated voice, so was unable to glorify the
Creator melodiously as he wanted to.
One Christmas in the Church of Blacierne, at the vigil of the Nativity, the Mother of God
appeared to him, holding in her hand a scroll which she gave him to eat.
As soon as he tasted it, an indescribable sweetness filled his mouth, and going up into
the Ambo, he began to intone in an angelic voice the contacune that has come down to us.
Today the Virgin gives birth to him who is above all being.
The gift remained with him for the rest of his life, through the inspiration of the Holy
Spirit he adorned most of the feasts of the liturgical year with wonderful hymns.
More than 1,000 contaccia are ascribed to him.
Some say that he also composed the renowned acethyst to the Mother of God.
Saint Romano's died in peace sometime after the year 555, to join the angelic choir, but
he so well represented on earth.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.